Some way.
My book is an optimistic book because I
argue about all of our,
uh,
our limitations and how empathy leads us
astray.
But in order to make that argument,
we also have to have an appreciation
that we're smart enough to realize that
empathy could lead us astray and that
we're smart enough to ask those to
override.
It's pernicious effects.
So it's empathy that causes me to favor,
uh,
somebody who looks like me over somebody
who does a tour or a somebody from my
country or ethnicity over a stranger.
But it's rationality that leads me to
say,
hey,
that's not reasonable.
There is no reason to do it.
It's not fair.
It's not impartial.
And so we should try to override
empathy.
And my outlook is very optimistic.
I'm a huge fan of reason and rationality
that we can work together and deliberate
and talk and argue and through this come
with some great accomplishments.
So what I argue is that we have the
capacity for rationality and reason.
This is actually fairly controversial in
my field.
Uh,
my fellow psychologists,
philosophers and neuroscientists often
argue that we're a prisoners of the
emotions that were fundamentally and
profoundly irrational.
And that reason plays very little role
in our everyday lives,
which is to say,
well,
determinism of a sword,
it's true.
Um,
what we,
what we do,
how we act,
how we think is a product of events that
have started a very long time ago plus
physical law.
We are just kind of pr.
We are physical creatures.
We are not,
we can't escape from causality.
So we'll just continue doing what we're
doing.
One of the main goals of my work is to
argue against that.
I think that notion is a more
responsibility can we reconcile with
determinism?
But I think determinism is correct,
but none of that challenges rationality.
And as an illustration,
you could imagine a computer that's
entirely determined,
but there's also entirely rational.
You could imagine on another computer is
entirely determined but as capricious
and arbitrary and random.
And so even in a deterministic universe
to question remains,
what sort of computer are we?
Are we are emotional creatures,
are we rational creatures?
But there is nothing,
not the slightest bit of inconsistency
between the claim that we live in a
determine universe and that we're
rational reasoning creatures.
I think it's worked with science.
Science is the paradigmatic case where
the exercise of reason by ESD is
imperfect.
People has come up with extraordinary
discoveries about the origin of the
universe to origin of life,
the atomic structure of material
objects,
amazing things.
And I think we could do the same thing
with mortality.
I think people can argue and deliberate
about morality.
Now,
whenever I say this and whenever I talk
about about empathy,
I always get a cynical response.
And the cynical response is I think
reasonable enough,
which is to say,
well,
that's not how it works in the real
world.
I was reminded recently that we're
supposed to live in a post fact world
right now.
Um,
the real,
in the real world,
people are persuaded by whoever yells
the loudest,
whoever appeals to their self interests,
whoever tweaks their emotions,
including empathy.
And I honestly don't doubt that that's
right.
In a short term.
I think that in any case,
if I want it to persuade somebody to go
to war against Syria,
to give money to this cause,
to expel that group from my country,
I would appeal to their emotions and
anybody who appeals to their emotions
would be much more successful in those
who attempt to make a rational
deliberate of argument.
But I think in a long run over time,
reason and rationality tends to win out.
I look at the world we're in now and for
all of its many flaws and problems,
I see signs of those moral
accomplishments all over the place where
I think we care more for people.
We had forgotten about that.
We have a broader moral circle as Peter
Singer would say.
We are less prone to kill each other as
Steve Pinker has demonstrated in his
work.
And there's a lot of explanation for
these changes.
But I think one key component has been
exercise of reason and I'm optimistic
we'll continue to see in the future.